it's weird causes people that want us to
work so much some people want life to be
about work and they want life to be
about money yeah and that's very
alarming to me yeah like I start to
really believe that there's gonna be a
thing where greed is not [__]
attractive anymore right like I want to
do well for myself like I want to
succeed yeah I want to have you know
there's some things I want to have all
my children to have like you know be
able to clean their teeth at night and
you know and like I feel like a
comfortable blanket on there scanning
things like that you know yeah but I
don't know if it's money I feel like
that drives me and if it really gets to
be like that that kind of scares me a
little
I wonder if that school of thought is
gonna start to take over that greed is
not it's not [__] cool anymore when
we know so much that other like beings
are struggling yeah man it's not cool
it's not it well in it and it's painful
I mean that's the you know when people
have a [__] ton of money yeah many of
them are philanthropists because they
figured out that like what is the best
feeling right giving it away yeah and so
they're they're they're philanthropists
and they're and they're giving it away
but generally like the experience of
selfishness is self-cherishing is
incredibly painful and people don't
realize that so yeah trying to load up
on money is act is is is a an attempt to
reduce their levels of suffering right
yes and that's a debt that I think
that's it that makes sense to me like if
it's like trying to put but the problem
yeah it's trying to put out a fire with
more fire yeah and it just doesn't work
it's just it's just that it's like oh
I'm thirsty god I'm so [__] thirsty
let me eat sand yeah that'll help me not
be thirsty anymore and and so I think
that's kind of the problem is what the
thing you're talking about I hope what
happens is that people start realizing
that because we're all connected I tend
to feel better if I'm doing stuff for
other people yeah more than if I'm doing
[__] for myself and that's what 12-step
programs are that's what all that is all
that as stuff is about usually is
getting back to realizing that the way
you get out of
whatever is hurting you a lot of times
is by helping somebody else you're not
thinking about yourself yes that's the
it's it's like if you want the antidote
to whatever ails you just start helping
someone yeah and you it's like so easy
to do it's you know right away like you
can do a scan right away and and think
who needs help in my life I'm not
talking about some kind of like distant
sending money off to charity or anything
like that that's great do it if you feel
like it I'm talking about
well this teacher jack Kornfield who
live out of my podcast he says tend to
the part of the garden you can touch so
just think like who who needs help who
needs a hug yeah I need somebody to take
on one - do you notice that's been
drinking a lot and and instead of joking
about it with your friends and making
fun of them which is okay to do yeah a
couple times more but also who could
probably is hurting and maybe could use
some you know and all they need is just
somebody to care yeah you know it's
crazy the scariest something the weird
and the weirdest what I was just
thinking about this a minute ago is
looking at Jen I was like how scary
would it be if I thought that you loved
me you know like not in like a
homoerotic type of way but how scary
would it be if we approached people and
the first thought we had was right that
this person loves me yeah yeah like
really like if you like it would that
would change the whole just changed it
would take me so much out of like
whatever fear that I lived in right but
it's for some reason that's not the way
that we are built to do it here and one
of the ironies about like bringing
slightly you know about bringing slavery
whenever they brought slaves to America
or probably anywhere really I better
specifically Americas we took these
people that probably didn't have that
probably had a lot of like neat
practices and they were probably down
earth practices and like yeah you know a
caring environment and then we bring
them into this place you know yeah but
that thing you're talking about the love
yeah this is that this
it can be cultivated so sometimes you'll
run into people who've cultivated that
and they do love you right around them
but it's an indignant so it's sort of
like that the idea is it like on one
level we have the ego identity mm-hmm
right which is just all our stuff and
the games that we play and all this
stuff like your identity as a podcaster
your identity as a comedian everything
that you do and then the other level is
like this soul level and that's love
that's your heart
that's this universal eternal identity
that that is so beautiful thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip and you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this because
this is alarming